si je vous dis une masse conique oui
qu'est-ce que c'est à votre avis ben une
grosille qui con quoi les fractions
qu'en pensez-vous dans un
problème je pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait
fraction dans tout problème
pourquoi sinon les assurances ne payent
pas comment peut-on calculer la valeur
de p à votre avis madame je pense que ça
ne se calcule pas de toute façon je
pense qu'il faut calculer le nombre de
litres à la journée c'est qu'une vache
est capable de donner 40 L de lait si
elle a 4 p qui fonctionne bien je vous
dis 314 116 à votre avis oh je pense que
c'est la région parisienne non la région
parisienne pourquoi oh bah le 3 quand on
met un se indicatif c'est la région de
Paris comment imaginez-vous l'absiss et
l' ordonné madame oh je ne sais pas le
la personne ordonnée évidemment sa
maison est tout de suite bien rangée et
et puis c'est peut-être aussi une
personne qui a les pieds sur terre qui
ça ben l'ordonné oui et l'absiss et
l'abscisse bon bah elle s'en va elle a
mieux courir dehors et évidemment elle
est peut-être plus utile à la société